I've seen things you people wouldn't
believe okay guys there's been a whole
bunch of stuff related to Blade Runner
2049 that has come out recently that I
want to talk about we got an initial
teaser look that honestly is not all
that much to go on but I'm basically
going to use it as a jumping off point
to talk about the project in general
because the director has also come out
and set a number of things that make me
interested as well and actually let's
start with the director I'm gonna put
his name up on the screen cuz i will
butcher it if i try and say but I was
not familiar with his work I knew of
movies that he made and I'd heard good
things about them but until this year I
hadn't seen any then I saw a rival I
loved arrival and now I that has given a
boost in terms of my assessment on this
project cuz I mean blit the ritual Blade
Runner is one of my favorite movies and
it became one of my favorite movies I
grew up on the lousy cut the one with
the voice-over so I've since discovered
that this movie that I loved is even
better as I've gotten a hold of you know
the better versions of this movie
directors cut in the final cut and so on
and normally I would have nothing but
concerning contempt but you know what
we've had some good revivals lately Star
Wars is back in a good way Mad Max fury
road this stuff can work now Ryan
Gosling has lead I'm torn on I'm not
sure either way because well I think
he's fairly decent I like him much
better when he is lively in things like
say the big short or or the nice guys he
was amazing in that but his is sort of
silent stoic thing that he does in
things like drive or the place beyond
the pines or whatever that thing was
called that it's not bad at it he
doesn't find but I just don't find him
as engaging when he does that and I
figure that's probably what they're
bringing him in to do here but you know
like I said he's not a bad actor so I'm
not going
and we got a glimpse of Harrison Ford
now the director has said Harrison Ford
is not really gonna be a co-lead in this
he will be there he will be featured but
he's not gonna be featured too heavily
would you my mind good I think that it's
the better way to end the directors also
said they won't definitively answer the
is Deckard a replica question which on
one hand good I don't think that ever
should be as definitively on the other
hand I'm like well you're gonna have to
integrate some new information about
replicants because by what we know when
the fact they're supposed to have a four
year lifespan the very fact that he's
still alive would normally answer that
question one way or the other so they're
gonna have to find a way to fudge that a
little bit but in general premise not
answering that question dude that's the
way to go it's also fairly going to be
rated R which I'm happy about and with
this director I'm fairly confident just
means that they will be free to explore
and bring in the violence as is
necessary not that it's going to be like
Deadpool and just revel in its already
not that there's anything wrong with
doing that but that's not what Blade
Runner is and the few glimpses we get of
the city look really consistent with
with the blade runner world that we know
which is good um I think probably as
long as you don't think too hard about
it because if this is basically as much
time has passed in the movie world that
has passed in the real world um
technology's changed a lot here since
the 80s so you'd think a similar amount
of time passing things would have
advanced but at the same time I don't
want them to because I want that same
world again so it becomes a case where
potentially the aesthetic and the
narrative might not totally gel we'll
see we'll see if it's something that
gets addressed or if they just hope you
roll with it and and maybe if they do it
well enough I will just roll with it and
it'll be fine again personally for me
the most comforting thing was just the
little bits of music especially at the
very end of that teaser it was Blade
Runner music cuz that soundtrack nothing
else sounds like that soundtrack it is
so gorgeous and so perfect and so unique
and I think
nobody else really tries to make
something sound like that because only
Blade Runner sounds like that only blade
runner looks like that only blade runner
feels like that and and if they can
recapture that and I think there's a
chance they can I'm reserving a little
bit of my anticipation but between what
I'm seeing what I'm hearing and what I'm
reading in terms of the mindset of the
director this could work and I would
really really really like it too so
that's sort of where I am right now with
blade runner 2049 have you seen this
teaser have you been reading the
interviews what's your thoughts on all
of this whatever they are drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to Like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at Council of
geeks give a listen to the counsel of
geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned